hey guys Pete peppers here and I was
gonna talk a little bit about the new
game from King that's coming out it
seems like the world over I released
this happened in real soon so I just
wanted to make a gameplay preview it's
called shuffle cats used cards that they
changed that and and the early versions
of the soft launch which came out a few
months ago there used to be two variants
there was regal rummy which is what you
play now and there was also diamond
whilst I think it was called the diamond
game is gone now but regal rummy was
kind of the better one anyways so here's
a shop I guess you can buy some things
this is new since the last time I played
it but it looks like you can talk you
can see this says this is free what is
it how do I get it that's what I'm
trying to do this is a chat pack all
right
so now I guess I have a special chat
setup all right so let's talk about the
game all right
this is a little bonus game that they
have you get to play free every once in
a while
so it's just picked what color the next
card is gonna be which is completely
random I'm just gonna collect because
it's 50/50 and no reason to gamble on
that you see there's a timer to get to
do that once a day see our shop here we
have free gems that we get every once in
a while that you want to collect as you
come back to the game so this here I am
level 5 and these are the streets there
used to be a ton of levels in the game
it seems like now there's only 13 but
we're gonna start at the beginning
anyways and we'll talk about how this
game works so each time you play it
costs a certain amount of gems and if
you win you get to keep the gem you get
a bonus if you lose then you lose
we'll watch the thing here to start you
take a card every time she had three of
a kind floors and so here you know I
just looked to see if I want the nine or
if I want to pick from the top of the
deck I don't need a nine because we're
playing rummy basically so I'll take my
three of a kind I'll lay that down and
just pick a card that you don't want and
put the desktop if you don't do that
quick enough it will discard one for you
so make sure you do that the way that I
think about the the cards off the stack
I don't take them unless I I can use
them right away in most cases you can
make an argument for picking up certain
ones like I could have picked up that
ace of diamonds I guess but it's I could
have pick up with a taste of diamonds I
guess but I wouldn't needed you know
something to go with it so see there I
won 60 gems for one in so like I said
it's basically it's pretty fun
rummy variant trying to think of some
things that are important to note you
can go around the the top which is
different and you can also add to the
other cards that re out there
so yeah the if you want to use I don't
need a so I'll pick the Queen or pick
that off the stack so these are suited
seven eight nine so I can play those and
now I just need to discard something
discard the check and now I have a four
card run right there I could maybe use
the King so I'll go ahead and take that
discard my run and that'll give me the
enough points to beat the level so like
I said you could play on the cards that
are down there so we could play if
there's three threes down there and we
have the last three in our hand we can
play it on there which is something that
comes up a lot that you might not think
about as far as I can tell on the gems
you can always come back and play these
levels if you really want to stack up on
them it might fix that later because
it's kind of
I don't have anything to play so tell us
oh yes I do
and I'll toss the two so she's gonna
play on this hopefully yeah now I can
play my three and four on that you could
do that both ways and they don't that'll
finish it off for me so like I said
these are really easy levels that you
can always win and right now at least
you can always go back there and pick up
more gems so once you get out of the
early levels
at least in the older version in which
I'm sure one say you can actually swap
cards if you want I don't usually do
that
but you play against other people you
don't play against the computer all the
time I don't have anything to play there
still don't everything to play
six goes with this but I don't have the
five so I'll just go ahead and pull off
the top you know place will pick up the
king and now I'll pitch this jack
so the things that play are pairs well
actually three years of three of a kinds
runs and then like I said you can play
off of their runs too so the way you
pick up your strategy is gonna vary you
want to kind of pay attention to what's
discarded you know like if if I was
going for a pair of kings and all the
kings had already been tossed there were
three or kind of kings and all of them
had been tossed you know that would be a
bad plan sometimes it's like this though
where you just don't get anything for a
bit so just go ahead and keep all right
there's my king now I can play that at
least
I'll pitch my queen since I have picked
up a queen not to so it doesn't do
anything 3 doesn't do anything but since
I've already just discarded a queen I'll
discard another one there's a 7 I can
use that
and I'll keep my to two paired cars and
hope that I get to improve or like this
I'll get to pick one up on the next so
that's basically it
I'll give I'll go ahead and finish this
round and then we'll talk about one
other thing that isn't at least at this
point not it's not that important yet oh
I could have played the king it's
something I you know you got to remember
I got a pickup for soon all right so
that'll I can play that one and I can
play I could have played the seven as
well so I've missed the spot there but
you get the idea
all right so this is lucky lining down
here this is what I'm saying it's not as
important at this point there's like
these big casinos that have large prizes
and you can see that people are you
could see how many players are inside so
way this works is you pay five fifty for
a chance to win a thousand which is much
more than you can win in the regular
levels if you're a odds person you can
see that over time unless you have a
huge advantage we're going to lose
eventually but I'm sure it's it makes a
little more fun to play when you're
playing for more and like I said right
now there's not a lot of there's not a
lot of levels on the regular part of the
board
so yeah the odds are even a little worse
on the gold bars but you could play
people for gold bars if you want and
possibly build up on those looks like I
have 150 I'm not sure if that's what
everybody starts with but
I'm guessing that we'll be able to use
these at some point this isn't unlocked
yet so that's the game I think it'll be
popular people who like card games
obviously you'll have you know plenty of
plenty of people playing it so you know
you'll be able to kill some time it's a
little little lower stress than some of
the other games so it's a good time
killer all right please like the video
if you found it helpful and make sure
you subscribe to my channel so that you
can get all the latest videos from the
level games that play my how to's and my
commentary videos I'll talk to you soon
yeah